Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder.
Ahem, auf geht's, Beta Field 5, Battlefield V, weil ich da letztens ja so schön wie die Leute draufgeregt habe.
So, was geht?
Oh, ist das... weg damit.
So, also erstmal Settings einstellen. Ich hab noch keine Runde gespielt, ich hab überhaupt keine Ahnung von dem Game.
Oh, oh man sieht den Aimbot im Hintergrund, fuck.
Guck mal, mein Mikro nimmt die Musik auf.
So, also Foff.
Moment, ich hab keinen Poggers Meme drin, das geht nicht.
Ich hab keinen... Nee, nee, nee, nee, das geht nicht. Den brauchen wir noch.
Moment, Moment, auf welchen Button mache ich den denn jetzt? Ich hab Null für ihn hier.
L, O, K ist noch frei, das brauchen wir bestimmt alles im Well, finde ich.
Das geht nicht. Sollen wir mal gucken, ob das automatisch hinzufügen geht?
Poggers, funktioniert. Hats haben sich unsere Programming Streams doch gelohnt.
Gut, gut, dass wir den Generic PNP Monitor am Start haben, bin ich ja froh.
Bisschen heller ist nie verkehrt. Der Sound passt glaube ich optimal zum Gameplay.
So hat sich das Dice auch gedacht. Motion Plur, also Plur ist mehr so wie...
So, Weapon Doof, Weapon Doof muss weg. Weg, brauchen wir nicht.
HDS, was? Play? Warum nicht? Ist das schlecht oder ist das gut?
Ich will doch immer meinen Foff haben, ich will doch nicht weniger Foff haben, wenn ich Iron Sight mache.
Oder will ich weniger Foff haben? Keine Ahnung.
Third Person Foff, BAM. Ich hab keine Ahnung, ich drehe jetzt zwar nicht so viel rum.
Aber Field of You, na Field of You, Klei of...
Hm, also 70 ist zu wenig, 120 wahrscheinlich zu viel, mal mal 100 oder so.
Jax, du hast es doch schon gespielt, was hast du denn Foff stehen?
Colorblind ist immer wichtig. In allen Battlefields sieht man mehr mit Colorblind. Mal gucken ob es dem auch so ist.
Foff hat es zu 90, okay. Mal die Pro Settings.
Ah, die S-Field of You, keine Ahnung, jetzt gucken wir dann.
Film Crane, öh.
Chromatic Apparati... brauchen wir alles nicht. Wie Knette, was ist denn wie Knette?
Eine Feminin ist wie Knette, was ist wie... Ach so ein Film-Effekt oder was?
wie ach so ein film effekt oder was
moment hat es jetzt gespeichert ja oder
ja ich brauche holt ja ist gut ich brauche
ironsights ironsights okay ironsights ist wahrscheinlich off hold
okay gucken wir mal mit schwedischem widerstandskämpfer grill im hintergrund
geht hier irgendwas
ja ja gibt gibt gibt hat kein bock darf man nicht auswählen oder was wird
das erkennt doch keine sau hallo select schwarz auf schwarz okay wir machen jetzt
mal den sound aus würde ich sagen
auf geht's full immersion voller immersion mode kommt jetzt wie als wärmer
dabei haben sie doch immer erzählt im vorfeld immer erzählt mein meme to
leckt guck mal ich schalte jetzt um und es kommt dass das das muss man noch
fixen leute guck mal wenn wenn ich den auspläne und pläne ihnen heiner leckt
kurz was das geht nicht pre-order nao
grant operations auch jetzt bastion alter bastion lautstärke hoffe ich mal das
okay sein wird okay warte mal aber gucken es kann sein dass wir es gleich die
ordnung pustet also full immersion mode
das stimmt was habe ich denn eigentlich jetzt eingestellt bei habe ich ja gar
nicht geguckt
ich muss wie so ein geschäft noch ausmachen post plus das muss auch weg
woher ist ich warum kann ich denn das ist ja mal bewegen hier ernst ja pizzi fast ja ja geht es mit
tastatur ja tastatur geht das crawling funktioniert nicht
doch jetzt geht's aber so geht es nicht das ist für sich die maßeschisten die
gönnen dann auch guck mal 0 3d leckt auch was jetzt join in game
ich lasse erst mal alles an können wir immer noch um rum editieren dann und
wir müssen wir müssen noch bettel lock und so geduldens gucken wie das aussieht
pre-alpha wenn der chat nerv kann ich den chat weg machen
no chat oh ist ist ist voice standardmäßig angeht den leuten jetzt auf den sack day
1 in norwegen oh jetzt kommt das jetzt kommt das
widerstandsquel gleich
wie ist die lautstärke moment per overlay traur fps 1
funktioniert ja auch sehr schön
hat warum habe ich 120 fps dass es geht das geht nicht dass das geht nicht
hat warum kann ich keine konnig klasse auswählen nur 100 fps das ist ja so geht
es ja nicht ich muss den stream kurz ausmachen weil wir auf dem anderen
monitor ist irritiert wo ja ja ich habe zu viel ram royale gespielt da muss man immer so laufen auf dem pferd
rein 80 fps was hier los das stimmt weil ich encode im hintergrund oder so tut man
sich weh so weit geht die immersion dann doch nicht also hübsch sieht der himmel
aus muss man sagen schneibers na was auch sonst wir sind im battlefield wahrscheinlich liegt die
hälfte des gegnerischen teams irgendwo da er ist das ja achja spotten gibt es
nicht mehr na ich erinnere mich gespottet moment für war habe ich kann rank abgekriegt
für was ich bin zwei ich bin zwei kilometer geradeaus gelaufen ich habe
nicht einen schuss abgegeben rack ab such an extreme
alles ruckelt das ruckelt was hier los ruckelt das pick up hell ok ich habe keine
ahnung was abgegeben zumindest ruckelt das erst mal squad mate ist auf mir gespornet
klar level ab sehr gut call for you aber jetzt alter jetzt ich glaube es nicht und
jetzt nix alter bist ich nix wie weg
die sense ist wie sie sehr schnell ok wo geht sie überhaupt lang dass das so was wie
russ oder dass das so was wie oh nein nein ironside sind auf hold muss aus das muss aus
ganz dringend aus was macht man jetzt eigentlich eine dofe frage was man ok oder oder plays ok
war ich weiß nicht was man muss ich dachte es gibt kein spotting warum sind die alle gespottet
bin ich bin ich medic bin ich irgendwie sowas in der richtung wie kann ich klasse wechsel
ok ich check ich check ich bin engineer glaube ich glaube ich bin sowas wie engineer
ornett hock toggle ironside das kann ich nicht spielen so was guck mal guck mal da kann man
auch nicht zielen direkt kann man auch nicht zielen
hallo spring alter ich sehe nix
hüpf hüpf
oh nein dieses ironside toggle hilfe gibt's lean action
ok da kommen jetzt wahrscheinlich die neuen spray pattern irgendwie zum toggle ironside
das ist absolut cancer hier leute
doch ich muss das ausschalten ich kriege anfälle
moment was ist gerade die spot oder so wo macht man wo macht man das aus controls basic
control advanced basic toggle wo ist das
wo ist hold wo ist hold vor zoom seht ihr das irgendwo leute
seht ihr das irgendwo
poggers leute krasser poggers ihr erkennt euch aus toggle
ist immer noch ist immer noch nicht ach ich hab sie so toggle gestellt ich bin auch dummer
oder jetzt wirds gebashed perfekt
debated
kann man jetzt kann man doch irgendwie robben in sicherheit war da nicht was
das ganz ehrlich das finde ich bescheuert ich weiß nicht ob ich es mitgekriegt habe
ich finde das ist sie labern ja immer was von von wegen von wegen immer schon und so
aber ich mein muss man den soldat in dem spiel nach seiner mutter rufen lassen wenn
er stirbt
ok man muss droppen aus dem flugzeug
ich check gar nix
falsche geht automatisch auf
also nicht die berühmte bedcompany crash geschichte
sinnloses gestrive geht ja auch noch das ist schön das ist gut zu wissen
wirklich reagieren kann man nicht wenn man beschausen wird
ok wir spielen jetzt erst mal als medic und stellen fest medic haben mp40 mp40 klingt
gut
ok es wäre cool wenn der falsche nicht automatisch auf gewiss dir dass man quasi so so anstelzen
kann so also runtersprung
ja so muss das sein
dann ist ja dass man quasi so wieder kurz vor der vor der erda aufmachen
oder jammert ja richtig er da will ich ja gar nicht auf linke maus tasten drücken
voll voll immersive platt experience auf der erde
jetzt jetzt gerätzt
wie funs wie funs ist mit spotten jetzt eigentlich genau man muss gegner angucken
irgendwie so war das was gegner angucken
ok 3s midi
ne 3s retz
ne wat
ach man hat nicht unendlich midi packs man muss die jetzt auffüllen
oder wie ist das
ja wahrscheinlich man muss die zu hausen muss man die auffüllen
ok das klappt nicht
ich hab zu wenig fps ich muss gleich mal ein bisschen grafikrunner schrauben
ich werfe ich werfe euch jetzt mal ein bisschen was hier neute gut
sag mal hat die hat die map auch deckung irgendwo
hinlegen hinlegen was ist hinlegen x
nein bitte was ist hinlegen ypsilon
ne knien ist scheuerung was ist denn hinlegen
x x
hinlegen ich will mich hinlegen
was was
also die fps sind schlecht
oh ich kann den retz retz was
oh neue retz animation
das war einer
ey hat die map deckung
oh da oben schneiberts
ich muss gucken wie man sich hinlegen kann leute
gibt es hier deckung
irgendwas
body sense viel zu hoch
kriegst du hier was nix
musik intensifies
ok jetzt müssen wir unbedingt erstmal einstellen
also wie
erstmal gucken wie man sich hinlegt
und und grafik runter stellen
wir haben gewonnen
mit 3 3 aber ich habe eindeutig dazu beigetragen
mp40 juggernaut ja
omega lul
alter ich finde es so geil die twitch memes sind überall mittlerweile
überall
der chat omega lul alles oh oh
200 fps poggers im hauptmenü
day 2
ach stimmt ja wir spielen operations
ganz vergessen
dachte es ist rush oder sowas aber ne gibt es ja net
rush gibts nicht leute
ernsthaft ne
ich hab irgendwo gelesen rush wirds nicht geben im fertigen game
was soll ich machen controls
hinlegen
bindings
keybindings
onfoot
save log da was sprint steady crouch
x hab ich doch gedrückt
an die crowd prone z
wollte mich verarschen
y
keine ami tastatur am start
so am ende ist jetzt wieder so leckt
mp40 als britte in 2k18
immer schon leute
alter was geht mir mein vira scanner auf dem 2 rechner ab
was ist das
jetzt müsst ich euch mal zeigen ja
den 2 rechner erzählt mir mein vira jetzt
for security reasons
access to host file has been blocked
das ist das windows update ne
wahrscheinlich was der im hintergrund installieren wird und avira spackt da rum
alter
was denn das
das ist ja epileptische anfälle
man verliert richtig geschwindigkeit beim springen
das ist ziemlich doof
kann man hier durch
wooo
netter animation
okay jetzt machen wir die mega krasse flank action des todes
jetzt werden sie alle geflankt
ich weiß es aber frag mich bitte nicht wo ich hinlaufe
wo sind da eigentlich gegner
gegner
ah nee fuck
krasser flank ist nicht von erfolg gegründet
flank source ja
oder oben geht was
wenns gebashed alter
geschreckt
ja respawn
okay das flanken hat sich jetzt nicht so krass gelohnt
das ist essenziell
alter da steht ja überall einer rum
main player aus der hüfte alles kein ding
können die mich jetzt eigentlich platt machen geht das
also können die mich jetzt platt machen
bestimmt oder du kannst bestimmt die leute die unten liegen platt machen
dass du das die halt nicht spawnen können
also es wäre sinnvoll
okay rumklitsch springen wie in battlefield 3 und 4 geht nimmer
hauptsächlich in battlefield 3
wow da ist einer drin
alter springt rüber
fuck wo ist er hin
aim na aim
ist hier einer oder was
hä was sagen mir was sagen mir denn die punkte da gerade
checksa da sind angeblich sind doch hier gegner
da ist keiner
warum sind da da punkte
doch einer
hä sind die punkte nicht live oder so
oder doch
hä ich
der fluss ist merkwürdig irgendwie
jetzt blitz
lass mich so mit meinen leuten krabbeln
ja ist egal
okay einfach respawn lassen
ja 80 fps ist ein gutes lp
man darf nicht vergessen
ich lasse nebenbei video rendern
wobei wenn man sich den chat oben anguckt
stimmt granat ist das g
smoke
okay g ist smoke und was ist frag
normal ist es nicht
also es ruggelt
ruggelt ist kacke
ruckeln ruckeln ist
der gandalf gandalf 1 war am starter
piss dich
ja ist ja gut alter
weil das ist jetzt
hinlegen
what
komplett squad
die fps ändern sich nicht auch auf
no low settings
wie kannst du das spiel jetzt schon spielen
ich weiß nicht ob ich sagen darf
dürfen wir das reveal
okay wir müssen jetzt mal was anderes ausprobieren
jetzt ist es überhaupt keine deckung
kann man fallschirm aufmachen beim runterspringen
ne
na gut ist ja auch kein bad company
okay pusherino pusherino action
okay keiner da
so smoke wie sieht denn das smoke aus
so
da ist angeblich was
ach nee das ist ein target
ach das ist ein target was mein squad gesetzt hat
oder so
okay wir gehen jetzt wir machen jetzt flank action
gucken wir mal ob das funktioniert in dem gandalf
what
suit gerettzt nice
wat
sag mal was ist das denn
Was ist, was ist das?
Ja, da muss ich jetzt auch nicht vor, vor, äh, Revive callen.
Okay, wir suchen mal, wir suchen mal eine andere Klasse raus.
Gucken wir mal.
Also für mich wirkt die Map irgendwie flach und, also, da sind zwar paar Häuser, aber da hat man nicht allzu viel von.
So, Support, was haben wir denn hier sonst noch am Start?
Schneiber, Schneiber, komm her Leute, Schneiber. Schneiber, Action.
Oh, das ruckelt, das ruckelt.
Kann man das geshaken?
What?
Okay, der, der, der, der, der Spielfluss ist, gewöhnungsbedürftig irgendwie gerade.
Ich, ich meine, ich war da bestimmt komplett an der falschen Stelle, ja, aber.
Okay, ähm, kann man die Klassen wechseln, wenn man...
Geht das? Was ist das?
Was? Vier? Äh, äh, ich check's immer noch nicht, ob die kleinen roten Punkte jetzt Gegner
sind und die großen roten Punkte objekte.
Hä?
Oh, Quicks, Scope, Scopesaw. Okay, die kleinen roten Punkte sind tatsächlich Gegner.
Alter, so, dafuck. Es ist, es ist BK4, äh, uuuh.
Okay, geh mal wieder MP40, rumgeschnallt, rumgeschnallt, ist keine so gute Idee.
Geh mal MP40, MP40, Juggernaut, Eats. Lass mich spawnen, spawnen.
Irgendwie kann man hier auch überhaupt nicht so richtig an der Seite lang, weil hier an
der Seite so offen, da bist du instant schreckt eigentlich, wenn du lang gehst.
Wow, was macht denn der hier? Bin ich ja selbst im Weg, es ist ja fast
so wie Rainbow Six. Rainbow Six hampeln auch so komisch rum.
Okay, Spray Pattern des Todes. Ich hab keine Schüsse mehr, dafuck, was?
Ich bin doch grad gespawned. Äh, but why?
Oh, Rätsel, Rätselhorn, Rätselhorn, nein. Habe ich denn keine, oh, keine Schuss mehr?
Okay, dann looten wir den Typ jetzt. What? Alter, was will mein Avira auf dem zweiten
Rechner? Okay, man hat verdammt wenig Schuss, wenn
man spawnet. Dann spawnen wir jetzt mal, was hat denn
der noch alles? Dann spawnen wir jetzt noch mal als Support
Stelle. Nee, komm, wir spawnen noch mal als Medic. Medic ist das Beste.
Medic muss man erst aufheben, okay. Das ist ja volle Immersion. So, was ist der
Marke hinter mir? Okay, das ist wirklich er. Okay, wartet mal, wartet mal kurz, Leute.
So 20%? Das fühlt sich an wie 75 oder so. Oh, warte mal. Ah, jetzt ist besser, jetzt
ist es besser. Was ist denn hier los, bitte? Was, bin ich nicht
als Medic? Ach nee, ich bin als komische Engineer-Stellzahler gespawnen.
Huh, what the fuck? Panzerstellz, kann man da einsteigen? Knapp.
Man hängt auch ziemlich viel an Gegenschirmen fest.
Alter, was beschießt mich hier denn? Hier ist doch nichts.
Okay, ich kriech jetzt mal hier rum. Easy kriech, easy life. Wo ist er? Ist mir der
Mann? Was schreit er denn so? Alter, hier ist ja, what? Ich hab jetzt keine Ahnung,
wo mich einer gekillt hat, ehrlich gesagt. Guck mal, geh mal nochmal. Medic, MP40-Stellz.
Also der Spielfluss ist wirklich enorm gewöhnungsbedürftig. Du hast überhaupt keine Ahnung, wo Gegner herkommen.
Aber vielleicht braucht das einfach nur so eine Zeit, bis man es checkt.
Und wisst ihr was mich gerade fragt? Wo kommen die Flugzeuge alle her? Hier gibt's keine,
hier gibt's kein Flugfeld. Wo kommen die denn her? Wie kommt man auf die Map? Wo, wo
kommen? Hier unten ist unten, ist hier unten ein Flugfeld? Nee, da ist mehr.
Habt ihr eine Ahnung, wo die Flugzeuge herkommen? Oder sportet man einfach in den Flugzeugen?
Erster Eindruck, ich blick null durch. Ich blick wirklich überhaupt nicht durch. Ich
hab keine Ahnung, warum jetzt auf einmal auf der linken Seite Gegner, ich check's nicht.
Das ist auf einmal am Start. Weiß nicht genau von wo. Wo soll ich wirklich in Deckung gehen,
weiß auch nicht. Die Flugzeuge spawnen in der Luft, das ist aber doof. Das ist aber
echt doof. Ok, weißt du was ich nicht gecheckt hab? Rotes, rotes Dreieck auf der, oh fuck,
rotes Dreieck auf der Map ist Objective vom Team Leader oder sowas. What, what? What?
Drip, you can't spawn. Also wenn man mit einer MP40 auf die Entfernung nicht sprain darf,
dann weiß ich auch nicht. Aber dafür ist das Ding doch da. Oh, der Mesh ist am Start.
Der Mesh kann jetzt mal erklären, wie das Spiel funktioniert, beziehungsweise woher
man weiß wo was ist. Weil ich hab absolut null Plan. Manchmal bin ich hier mitten in
Plauen und dort zu Gegner am Start und bei den, ich selbst weiß nicht wo die, also ich
check's gerade null. Ok, das ist mehr oder weniger erste Runde. Ok, die kletschen da
so vor sich hin. Aber ich check's null. What, what? Warum hat er mich jetzt getroffen? Ich
bin halt zwei Sekunden draußen. Ok, noch mal Flank Action. Hier ist Katze halt überhaupt
nicht rüber. Smoke, hat er noch was anderes als Smoke? Oh, ich komm mir so mega unfähig
vor gerade. Hellstrike gibt's nicht mehr. Ok, das war nur Rektor. Wo ist denn hier was?
Also ich bin nicht fähig das zu, zu understanden, ja. Von allen Seiten, nein, nein, nicht, nicht
updaten, Windows, Windows, nicht updaten. Later. Alter, will's updaten, stopp's nicht.
Ok, mal den Krampel. Nein, gerade kein Bock zu sterben, ok. What? Warum ist hier laufen
um jede Ecke einer, ey? So, wir spawnen jetzt mal mit was anderem. Muss erst mal warten.
Max 0,20, nee, irgendwie 2,20 oder so. Ich hab, ich checke den Spielfluss null, Leute,
null. Die Map ist auch irgendwie so offen. Irgendwie Schneefeld mit bisschen Häusern
und Waggons. Ja, eher das Gefühl hab ich auch irgendwie. Das hat null, also bis jetzt
zumindest irgendwie, so null, dass du irgendwie weißt, was wo ist. Also ich check's halt einfach
noch nicht. Oh, das ist hässlich, das Ding, ey. Alter, das ist hässlich. Ach, das ist
meiner. Oh, das ist hässlich. Das Ding, kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, das war früher
in jedem, in jedem 2. Weltkrieg Shooter drin, das Teil, äh, hinter uns? Ernsthaft? So,
in den Kopf, äh, wat? Oh. Was macht der denn da? Oh, der retzt mich. Das ist nice. Ein
nicer Dude ist das. Der retzt mich. Wo sind die Gegner? Die waren doch hier noch irgendwo
am Start. Oder auch nicht? Gegner, Gegners, nicht runterklitschen. Nicht runterklitschen,
Alter, nicht runterklitschen. Wat? Oh, oh. Der hat doch nicht mal Line of Sight zu mir
gehabt, jetzt. Oh, noch mehr retz, nice. Jetzt geht's ab. Get the Reno. Warte mal, Fle.
Geh auch mal kurz rüber. Guck mal da mal von der Seite rein. Nein, nicht rüberspringen,
du reingucken, Alter. Jetzt komm mal vor. Kill, Vorgass, ja. Ja, das klappt schon, also
wenn ich, also eh mal, das ist ja Standard, wenn man, wenn man neu ist. Nee, der ist da
schon. Das ist ja neu, dass man nichts checkt. Wobei, also ich hab, ich hab so ein doofes
Gefühl, dass man den Spielfluss infini checkt. Also wenn es jetzt Rush wäre, würde ich jetzt
ganz nach links gehen und einfach in die gegnerische Base flanken. So, was machen wir jetzt? Wir
tun jetzt einfach so, als wäre das Rush. Easy Rush. Da kommt man nicht rauf. Was war
das denn, ey? Äh, übrigens, Helzanzeige viel zu klein. Viel zu klein, scheiße, platziert.
Helzanzeige ist in der Mitte, in der Mitte als Balken unten, weiß auf weiß, überhaupt
nicht im Sichtfeld, wenn man auf Gegner guckt. Und, und getrennt von Munition und Granaten.
Scheiße, also Scheißposition für, für Helzanzeige, eindeutig. Sackt. Oh, wir, wir wiegen jetzt
einfach ein bisschen. What? Alter. Okay, wir schneibern, wir schneibern uns jetzt auch
mal einen ab. Ich hab gelesen irgendwo, dass es Rush nicht geben soll. Der Meshed weiß
da bestimmt mehr. Ich hab, ich hab gelesen, Rush gibt's nicht. Oh, oh fuck. Ich muss
irgendwie ein bisschen an die Seite. What? Kein Hitz, okay. Kann man, okay, wie hält
man Luft an? Kann man hier durchschneibern? Ja. Der Typ stellt's da doch drinne rum, könnt
man. Ja, der stellt's da auch drinne rum. Boah. Ich warte mal, Moment, mal kurz recken.
Ah, man reckt nicht mehr. Fuck, stimmt ja. Rückzug. What? What? Okay, das, das, das
Game verwirrt mich. Das Game verwirrt mich echt, ey. Ah, ja. Ähm, Rush war die letzten
Teile, Teile fast tot. Ja gut, die letzten Teile war Rush auch. Scheiße. Ich kann wundern,
dass Rush tot war, die letzten Teile. Warten mal, Leute, ich brauch mal kurz aufwunderte
Musik. Josh, das ist das beste Squad.
Next. Rush now. Nein, nein. Nicht Rush now, ich will, Rush will ich now als Spielmodus.
Ja, ich muss sagen, die Karte überzeugt mich jetzt auch noch nicht so richtig. Warte mal,
ich sag schon richtig balls, ja, ich weiß, aber trotzdem. Die Map ist merkwürdig. Okay,
Moment. Jetzt sind wir wieder Attacker. War wir eben grad schon, aber das macht ja nix.
Guck mal, das Flugzeug geht zur Seite. Meine Immersion. Jopsie ball. Das ist beste Kombination.
Dann hält man das besser aus. Ich finde, muss ich ehrlich sagen, die Musik verstärkt
die Immersion auch schon noch ein ganzes Stück, ne? Oh, was? Oh, oh.
Wow, ich kann nicht ratzen, Alter. Okay, Flanker, Reaver, ich muss jetzt mal
rein. Okay, Flanker, Reno, ich renne da jetzt nicht in die Mitte rein. Kann man, kann man,
kann man? Geht das? What? Von wo? Kann man irgendwen Scheiß kaputt machen? Damit vielleicht?
Ah, okay. Meine Sense hat sich geändert zwischen beiden Runden. So, der sieht gut aus.
Dann gehen wir jetzt rein. Ah. Los. Es wäre cool, wenn da Fallschirm nicht aufgehen würde
alleine. Und, dass man mehr steuern kann. Guck mal, in Bad Company 2 konnte man abspringen,
Fallschirm ein bisschen zulassen, dann konnte man bis zu dieser komischen Hürde da vorne
stelsen. Ah, the fuck? But why? Oh, ist das schon da? Warum sieht er mich? Warum kann
er in unseren Spawn gucken? Warum? Und warum reg ich mich nicht mehr selbst? Ich bin am
Spaziergang. Oh, Minecraft. Spitzhacke. Hä? Ah, das ist eine Tür. Ich hab's nicht gecheckt,
aber warum hat man so einen Teufel Interacte dann da? Okay, wichtiges Haus, essentiell.
Also, ohne das Haus würde definitiv nichts gehen. Oh, man regt sich? Regt man sich im
Haus? Nee. Regt man sich? Habt ihr... Leute, ich hab's jetzt nicht gesehen, weil ich muss
mal sagen, die Helzleiste ist super platziert. Ähm, regt man sich selbst? Hast du noch Kontakt
zum Friseur? Klar. Claro, ich hatte schon vor YouTube Kontakt zum Friseur. Ach guck
mal, hier ist Zeug. Sehr nice. Helz, hat er es jetzt geschluckt? Warum sehen die mich
nicht? Okay, wir testen mal das Spotting. Warum ist es jetzt schwarz geworden, gerade
wenn man fragen darf? Und warum greif ich den nicht? NA. Pur NA. Wird man eigentlich
civil, wenn man schießt? Wie ist mein Eindruck? Es ist übelst chaotisch, ich blicke null
durch, das ist mein Eindruck. Spotting, Spotting, Achtung, krasser Spotterino Action. Was ist
das für Musik? Okay, was auch immer, einfach mal in die Richtung. Alter, das Game, ey,
das Flanking ist so sinnlos. Das ist keine saubere Art, die ich beschreiten kann. Das
ist die Ingame Musik, ja? Was meinst du denn? Was hat er das gedacht? Da ist er, da ist
er. Jetzt wird er gebasht, jetzt wird er richtig krass gebasht, sag ich euch mal. C'mon, komisches
Ding. Muss man jetzt in BF eher so CS schießen machen, so irgendwie Single und, und, und,
aber jetzt w knives fast, und. Gedulds. Okay, nix da, wahrscheinlich kommt jetzt eh gleich
gleich einer von der Seite und wreckt mich, weil ich dran denke, dass er da ist.
Oh, dahinter, hinter mir.
Alter, was ist das für ein...
Okay, das ist das neue Recoil Handling, ich hab's verstanden.
Neues Recoil Handling. Und meine Munition ist alle nach einem Gegner, zwei Gegnern.
Was?!
Sag mal, warum ist man immer One-Shot gefühlt, ey?
Was ist das?
Die Musik und das Geschrei passen echt, guck mal, was ich sag.
Ah, ne, man kann das nur nehmen, wenn man gedamaged ist, okay.
Flankerino.
Was hat er da jetzt?
Au!
Was? Was war das?
Warum hat's mich das jetzt gerade über die halbe Map geworfen?
Wo sind die Gegner?
Kann man jetzt irgendwie Cock-Action machen, hier so?
Wow, come on, aber das ist... What?!
Alter, ich war hinter der Kiste?
Das Game ist mir echt zu hoch, das ist zu advanced, das Battlefield für mich.
Das ist eindeutig zu advanced.
Okay, wo könnte jetzt ein Gegner herkommen?
Außer von gerade, von rechts.
Von rechts kommt was, oder?
Kommt was von rechts?
Warum ist der jetzt da? Der war doch eben noch links.
Ich check den Fluss nicht, ich kapiere den Spielfluss nicht, echt nicht.
Die Gegner sind immer genau da, wo ich da hingucke.
Das ist echt schlimm.
Sind wir jetzt woanders?
Ich bin der Oberplatt in dem Gamer.
Kann man hier drauf?
Okay, so ist das mit Recoil-Pattern wahrscheinlich nicht gedacht, oder?
Piss dich, Alter, piss dich!
Der soob nicht mehr, der soob nicht mehr rein, man!
Mein ADS ist kaputt gewesen.
Alpha, Alpha.
Okay, wir probieren jetzt nochmal MP40 aus.
MP40 muss doch was taugen.
Ich glaube, die Minimap ist unscharf, bis einer so einen Flare abschießt.
Das habe ich schon gecheckt.
Also ich vermute es gecheckt zu haben.
Okay, jetzt ist er hier.
Piss dich, Piss dich, Windows!
Alter, muss das jetzt echt sein?
Oh man!
Laut, der Map war doch direkt hinter einer.
Da ist links noch einer.
Links noch einer.
Achtung, ich bin jetzt geschreckt.
Er ist schon geschreckt.
Piss dich!
Oh nee, da war noch einer.
Windows, äh...
Hat er... wie heißt er?
Nidala?
Nadella?
Hat er zugeschlagen.
Der Inder.
My name is Peter.
Kennt ihr das?
Kennt ihr den Inder?
Den Peter?
Den Inder?
Peter?
My name is Peter?
Ich will spavnen.
Lass mich spavnen.
Kennt ihr diesen Microsoft-Mitarbeiter, der sich meldet?
My name is Peter?
Oder der Inder, der kommt halt irgendwie aus Indien oder so?
Danke für Ihre Geduld.
My name is Peter?
Hallo, rausspringen.
Da sieht man auch, wie kacke die Map ist.
Hör mich schon mal die Map an.
Flach, Hügel, Haus, fertig.
Pupke in HD.
Naja, also dass man laufen und Sachen hängen bleibt, ist wie Pupke.
Das stimmt.
Okay, mal kurz in mich gehen, Leute.
Woran könnte ich jetzt wissen, ob da ein Gegner ist?
Woran könnte ich das erkennen?
Ich sehe, ich versuche jetzt mal nicht, das Spiel irgendwie reinzulegen.
Ich sehe, die Gegner haben drei Objective, wir haben keins.
Mein Leute sterben da vorne.
Angeblich ist hier...
Ich kann nicht aufstehen.
Doch, bitte aufgestanden.
Angeblich ist jetzt hier ein Gegner.
Aber hier ist keiner.
Warum ist hier keiner?
Er war doch eben hier.
Angeblich zumindest.
So, Yolo.
Vorderwand muss schneibern.
Das Video mit Peter war auf...
Alter, piss dich.
Ich habe den noch nicht mal gesehen.
Wo ist der denn überhaupt?
Achtung, wir smokeen uns jetzt selbst ein.
Nein, machen wir nicht.
MP40, ja.
Ja, ist klar.
30, 30 Schuss auf den Gegner.
One hit, easy, easy clap.
Kann man Sniper auch ohne Scope spielen?
Geht das?
Oder Engineer ohne hässliche, fette LMG?
Kann man Medic vielleicht mit...
Ja, Medic mit K43.
Ja, da ist das Spielrad.
Deploy, deploy, deploy, deploy.
So, ich zeige euch jetzt mal Peter.
Wartet mal.
Peter, den indischen Support-Mitarbeiter.
Das war von G-Data, ein Werbevideo.
Das war übelst lustig.
Inder, keine Ahnung.
Ja, genau, genau.
Ihr müsst mir sagen, ob es laut genug ist jetzt.
Wartet mal, ich mache mal mitten rein.
Jawoll, habe ich.
Ist es laut genug?
Ja, Peter.
Jetzt bin ich hier auf fastsupport.com.
Der Keller hat ein bisschen an wie Kronk, oder?
Ist es laut genug?
Irgendwo hier kommt jetzt Peter gleich.
Nicht laut genug.
Copyright.
Ach was, Copyright.
Der 2K.
Was?
In Quarantier.
Ja, danke sehr.
Okay, sie leitet ihn weiter zu Peter.
Man denke dran, es ist ein indischer Support-Mitarbeiter mit Krach im Hintergrund, der angeblich Microsoft Super Elite Premium Gold Partner ist.
Und aus Indien kommt.
Aber pass mal auf, mit welchen Namen er sich jetzt gleich meldet.
Ich bin noch da, ja.
Ich komme schon immer wieder weg von meinem Typ.
Seems legit.
Ruf es den Indien an.
Hallo, ich heiße Peter.
Na wie dann sonst?
Wie heißt man auch in Indien anders?
Natürlich Peter, wie sonst?
Das ist so dumm, ey.
Oh Leute, wir brauchen Kirby Musik.
Oh mega Upload.
Oh nein, Leute.
Nein, nein, bitte nicht.
Nicht den Mega Upload Song.
Da ist was gerannt.
Okay.
NA.
Richtig, NA.
What?
Alter.
Was geht da oben ab?
Fliegt der oder was?
Übrigens, ich habe absichtlich, nur bevor einer jetzt wieder ankommt, NA-Aim.
Ich habe absichtlich davor geschossen, weil ich denke, das Ding muss da hinfliegen.
Aber das hat nicht funktioniert.
Also es war nicht so extrem, ey, wie es ausgesehen hat.
Nein, nein, Leute.
Wir machen nicht den Mega Upload Song.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Nicht den Mega Upload Song.
Nicht den, komm Leute.
Das kann ich halt mal an den Mega Upload Song.
Was irgendwie?
Nee, wie ging das?
Ich weiß gar nicht.
Woran weiß ich denn jetzt, von wo ein Gegner kommt?
Woran erkenne ich das?
Ich habe nie Conquest gespielt.
Wie?
Woran erkenne ich das jetzt?
Von da.
Okay.
Easy.
Easy clap.
Von da kommt er.
Da ist er.
Bam.
Nein.
Da war er.
Nate.
Bam.
Okay, der macht mich Spawn-Hit fast.
Gefühl auch gut.
Wo ist er?
Das kleine Fützchen.
Da ist er.
Alter, NA, NA, extrem.
NA ist tot.
Wo ist der Gegner eigentlich hin, gerade, wenn ich mal fragen darf?
Oh, da ist Bear Grylls.
Ich habe Bear Grylls verrecken lassen.
Face.
Okay, also wenn in einem Shooter was klappt, dann Aufgang Treppe-Campen.
Kommt noch was?
Oh.
Okay, Achtung, wir stellen uns jetzt mal hier durch.
Da muss ja irgendwo was kommen jetzt.
Sie ist doch auf der Minimap.
Ist nichts.
Alter, das ist NA des Todes, ey, das kann doch kein...
What the fuck, warum machen die so viel über Damage?
Mein Gott, bin ich scheiße, ey.
Kannste ja kein zeigen, ja.
Ich vorbeischieße mit dem Kack.
Muss unbedingt mal ein bisschen mehr spielen, wieder.
Ist ja der Wahnsinn.
Face marks, ja.
Ja, da müsste ich noch den machen, abzu.
Kann man von dem Ding vielleicht das Scope runter montieren?
Warte mal, ich mach mal eine Sache, ist mir ein Tick zu langsam.
So was da, so ein Zwischending.
Omega Roll When.
Moment, hat es gerade nicht gehitted, das erste?
Das erste hat nicht gehitted, oder?
Und es dreht man durch.
Wie er schreit, Alter, retz mich, retz Blitz, retz Blitz.
Nein, gibt's nicht.
So, Automatik, besser.
Hat der einen schon was anderes?
Oh, was, das brauchen wir.
Was ist das hier?
Das sieht aus wie das Rotten, das ist nicht das Rossische.
Das Spiel sieht unfassbar scheiße aus.
Ich finde, optisch ist das gar nicht so übel.
Warum ist die Minimap so geplurrt?
Die ist so geplurrt, weil keiner flährt.
Warum ist das geplurrt?
Warum ist die einfach ausgekraut?
So, kann man die hochklitschen irgendwie?
Geht das?
Ich will den Battlefield 3 hier hochklitschen.
Go, go, klitsch hoch.
Alter, haben die das nicht in der Ausbildung beigebracht?
Kriegt man, wie man klettert?
Ich sehe nichts.
Okay, da hat mich jetzt einmal auf den Preis.
Das leckt.
Leute, ich glaube, jetzt checke ich, warum sich das Spiel so komisch anfühlt.
Ich glaube, es leckt einfach nur wie Sau.
Ohne Scheiße, ich glaube, es leckt einfach nur wie Sau.
Ich glaube, das ist es.
Ernsthaft jetzt?
Ich glaube, es leckt einfach nur wie Hölle.
Der Film hat ja auch so etwas geschrieben eben.
Aber jetzt fällt es mir gerade so richtig auf.
Auch wie sich die Treffer anfühlen und so.
Okay, wo kriege ich jetzt Muni?
Wo kriege ich Muni?
Warte, wo kriege ich Munition?
Wo ist der Gegner?
Okay, wo kriege ich Gegner?
Hier, bei dem, bei dem Dude.
Hebe ich auf.
Er.
Alter.
Lass mich aufheben.
Alpha.
Alpha, ich sag nichts.
Five IQ Player.
Big Brain.
Was haben wir für krasse Stats?
Zehn zu zwölf.
Yeah, das wird ja voll mal ansprüchengerecht.
T-60.
Lacken und gleich licken, das ist richtig sehbar.
Er hätte es uns nicht gesagt, hätten wir das nicht gewusst.
Ja, das Lack, wie Hölle, Alter.
Habt ihr die Einschläge von den Schüssen gerade gesehen?
Claymore-Switch mach ich gleich.
T-60-Claymore-Switch.
Hab ich denn hier Claymore sogar?
Achtung.
Huh?
Claymore?
Geht als Claymore durch, oder?
Oh nee, da kommt von links was.
Was klaust du, mein Kill?
Warum hast du meinen Kill geklaut?
Soller Scheiß.
Was?
Was zum Teufel?
Warum?
Warum macht der mehr Damage mit seiner verkackten Pistole, ey?
Ich mein, ich hab aufs Bein geschossen, aber das Battlefield macht überall gleich viel
Damage aus seinem Kopf.
Benutzt man alles Quad-Punkte?
Wie?
So?
Ne.
Was ist das?
Ihr benutzt nicht überhaupt Quad-Punkte.
Das ist einfach in Australien, ich weiß nicht, wie es sich fühlt.
Außerdem ruckelt es.
Das ist das Allerschlimmste.
Es ruckelt.
Ich krieg Anfall übers Spiel in die Rocker, kann sogar richtig zielen.
Nicht, dass ich was treffen würde, aber dann hätten wir nicht die Chance.
Achtung, Achtung.
Ah, piss dich, piss dich, Alter.
Was?
Von wo?
Ping, kann man Ping einblenden?
Geht das?
Ich weiß nicht, wie man Ping einblendet.
Falls der Finn noch da ist, Finn, du kennst doch bestimmt die Konsolenbefehle, oder?
Das geht doch bestimmt mit dem Ping.
Oder weiß das einer von uns?
Also ich kenne es nur, das FPS-Overlay.
What?
Ah.
Okay.
Perf.
Aber es geht ja schon ein bisschen besser als...
Draw.
F-Cat?
Nee, was ist das?
Woah, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das wollen wir nicht.
Von hinten, von hinten ordnet uns einer.
Oh Mann, Sandwich.
Steht das in dem Scoreboard?
Ach doch, LOL.
Tap, Tap in 2K80, aber es macht nichts, lag trotzdem.
Das merkst du extrem bei den Schüssen.
Du hittest die, du hittest die, du hittest die, die ersten paar zählen nicht und dann
ist der Gegner in Deckung.
Und er macht Bloop und er fällt um.
Ganz, ganz merkwürdig.
Also es ist nicht, das ist nicht Late-Ziel.
Lag.
Das ist, das fühlt sich an wie Server-Lag.
Also wie Server-Lag, also der kommt nicht mehr rausgelassen oder so.
Aber immerhin, 8 FPS, äh, 8 Ping.
Habt ihr noch andere schöne Musik, sowas wie Kirby?
Super.
Besser, riech mich nicht so auf.
Lebt der jetzt noch oder nicht?
Ok, Spray-Pattern.
LOL.
Achtung, ihr stellts nirgends rüber.
Oh, da ist noch einer.
Wie kommt man hier eigentlich rein?
So und ich.
Bestimmt die allerbeste Waffe für die Range.
Oh, ich hab keine Munition mehr.
Kriegt man die hier?
Wo kriegt man eigentlich Munition?
Wo ist Munition?
Ah.
Nein.
Wo?
Moment.
Wo gibt's eigentlich Munition?
Halt sie um!
Nope.
Geht nicht.
Ist ja kein Bad Company.
Ah, hier gibt's Munition.
Midi-Picks?
Ammo?
Aha, Ammo.
Midi-Picks.
Krieg ich schnell.
Gibt, gibt kein Midi-Picks.
Wenn ich jetzt hier rübergehe, werde ich übrigens geschwackt.
Schwackt.
Schwackt!
Ha!
Evaded.
Was auch schlimm ist, man kann nicht, man kann die Maus nicht drehen im Aufstehen.
Nein, kein Mega-Upload-Song.
Was war das?
Instant-Spawn.
Das war Instant-Spawn.
Aber Totspawn, Totspawn.
Der Epic Sachs-Guy.
Na, na.
Irgendwelche Gaming-Musik.
Was ist mit dem los?
Nein, nein, den Mahat-Will-Go-On-Flöten-Typ spielen wir auch nicht.
Irgendwas.
Hat das irgendeinen Sinn, mit den geplörten Punkten auf Blocken auf der Map, oder ist
das...
Hat das was mit den Gegnern zu tun?
Ich renne jetzt nicht direkt rein.
Man sieht hier auch nix drinnen, das ist der Mega-Sack.
Komm, man sieht nix.
Geh ich noch?
Was?
Nein, ich wollte da nicht drauf klettern.
Da ist ein Gegner.
Richtig.
Tja.
Man hört übrigens null.
Man hört null Gegner.
Also absolut keine Schritte.
Und das nicht wegen Kirby-Musik.
Was?
Das kommt, es kommt wirklich komplett von allen Seiten.
Es ist ein komplett random Spiel-Gefühl.
Spielt sich das nicht einst als wie Battlefield 1?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich hab Battlefield 1 und die Beta, äh, die Alpha und Beta, Alpha und Beta, glaube ich,
gespielt.
Und dann hatte ich keinen Bock auf das Game.
Es geht mir nicht ganz so sehr auf den Sack wie Battlefield 1.
Aber ich will das hängen bleiben, das ist ja auch der Wahnsinn, ey.
Warum hab ich schon noch 65 Leben?
Okay, wir stell's.
Achtung, wir machen jetzt Sensitiv.
Sensitiv stell's.
Der ist, der ist verbuckt.
Guck, der ist verbuckt.
Sensitiv um die Ecke stell's.
Der ist verbuckt.
Der klitscht immer in die Wand rein.
Geht, geht, geht, geht.
Okay.
Ähm, zwei.
Nice, ich wird geheilt.
Ich glaub's nicht.
Ich wurde geheilt.
Dreckt.
Wo ist denn das scheiß Baum?
Dreckspotting.
Ey, wollten sie das nicht irgendwie fixen?
Wow.
Einfach mal drei Gegner nehmen bei mich.
Oh.
Habt ihr das gesehen, wie das geleckt hat?
Leute, habt ihr das gesehen?
Ich hab auf den geschossen.
Ich hab kleinzeit wahrscheinlich Trefferfeedback gekriegt.
Dann bin ich gestorben.
Und als ich tot war, hab ich einen Headshot-Gegner-Kill gemacht.
Fünf Sekunden später.
Das ist, ich sag euch, das ist kein Latency-Lag.
Das ist Server-Side-Lag.
Lächerlich ey.
Kein Wunder, dass ich das so kaputt anfühlt.
Aber es ist ja auch kaputt.
Monka-S.
Monka-Giga.
Okay, man muss das Ganze ein bisschen langsamer spielen.
Bin ich ein Schmeddich?
Nein, Leute, bin ich nicht.
Was?
What the fuck?
War das mit der Pistole?
Das lag wie Sau.
Das ist Raspberry-Pies.
EA-Server ey.
Wahrscheinlich sind die bei Peter gehostet.
Was geht mit dem hier ab?
Peter hostet, wenn er nicht gerade Leute scammed, EA-Server irgendwo in Indien.
Mein Name ist Peter.
Monka-S.
Was ist hier los?
Pogas-Pok, Pok, Pok, Pok, Pogas-Pok, Pok, Pok.
Ich hab' die noch gekillt.
Möcht ich schon mal anmerken.
Das ist...
Also, übst du es auch mal, Lächer?
Krasser Scheiß.
Das ist natürlich zu spielen.
Also, ich werde jetzt auch bevor ich irgendwie um das Game flamme oder so, ich werde es noch
mal in Ruhe spielen, falls das noch morgen läuft, mal gucken.
morgen vormittag oder so
falls es nicht leckt
das keine es ist ja doch zwar dass es ja ist recht pro matrix war es ist
So was haben wir sonst noch kermi musik
Was was gibt es denn sonst noch 10 hours ich weiß was
Am auspackt
So passend immer für die immersion leute
Immersion wird groß geschrieben
Kann man schalldämpfer drauf machen auf das ding ok ich habe es noch nicht gecheckt
Ich habe noch nicht gecheckt wie squad punkte einlöse
Kann ich so schwer sein
Löse ich squad punkte ein
Und wie ich waffen customise das ist auch ist es für mich jetzt im jui auch nicht so richtig ersichtlich gerade
C. Ah also in game C. Ok
C
C kommt bei mir nichts
Ah jetzt
Warte mal
C